l'hôpital souffre d'un manque de
personnel comme jamais la France reste
l'unique pays européen à ne pas
réintégrer les soignants non vaccinés
depuis la crise du covid une
personnalité politique prend énormément
la défense des non vaccinés notamment
sur Twitter c'est Florian Philippot donc
demain cela fera 500 jours pile que des
travailleurs français sont suspendus
pour non vaccination covid qui a unique
au monde des infirmières des pompiers
des médecins administratifs etc alors
plus que jamais réintégrer les suspendus
voilà ont à la macronie infâme voilà
alors Philippot dans toute sa finesse
habituelle
ouais alors de combien il y a une
question qui revient très souvent dans
mes c'est pas la première fois qu'on me
la pose Cyril alors je suis plus mince
en charge de la santé mais j'assume
parfaitement d'avoir demandé à des gens
qui sont au contact de personnes
fragiles ou malades d'être protégés
contre un virus transmissible ce serait
une première dans l'histoire je pourrais
comprendre que ça crée de mémoire il se
trouve que moi j'ai été blouse blanche
aide-soignant médecin
et que pour intégrer l'hôpital quand on
m'a demandé de mettre la blouse premier
truc on m'a demandé c'est mon certificat
de vaccination contre le DTP et
l'hépatite pourquoi
parce que tout ce qu'on peut faire pour
éviter de transmettre des maladies à
l'hôpital mais on le fait ça fait partie
de notre éthique professionnelle
premièrement ne pas nuire premier
principe Hippocrate donc on a demandé
aux soignants alors il est soignants qui
n'ont pas voulu se vacciner initialement
parce qu'ils disaient l'ARN messager etc
je note juste Cyril que il disait
lorsqu'il y aura un vaccin traditionnel
on fera bon on a mis un vaccin
traditionnel c'est le novavax qui
correspond à bien des vaccins ancestraux
ça a pas fait bouger du tout le nombre
de soignants
on parle là d'environ c'était les
derniers décomptes et c'était il y a un
moment on parle de 1000 personnes 1000
blues blanches sur 300 000 d'accord qui
sont concernés je dis pas que c'est rien
ça compte la plupart d'entre elles en
tout cas on a systématiquement proposé
d'accompagner les soignants qui ne
voulaient pas se vacciner vers une
reconversion professionnelle etc
certains ont accepté d'ailleurs beaucoup
leur accepté d'autres n'ont pas voulu
certains ont fini par ou attraper le
covid et une fois guéri avec un
certificat à revenir d'autres ont fait
le choix de se vacciner etc moi
dans ma conception de l'éthique
professionnelle je dis juste que si
demain on doit développer des vaccins
contre des maladies potentiellement
transmissibles transmissibles et
potentiellement sévères ce sera une
bonne nouvelle et que si c'est vaccins
là ils existent on demandera à nouveau
soignants se vacciner Thierry pour moi
je vais même aller un petit peu plus
loin pour moi le combat a mené
aujourd'hui c'est davantage un combat
pour augmenter par exemple le taux de
couverture vaccinelle des soignants
contre la grippe parce que la grippe
quand on la chope à l'hôpital quand vous
êtes fatigué que vous avez 80 ans vous
venez vous faire soigner à l'hôpital
c'est pas pour rattraper la grippe donc
pour moi ces combats ils sont plutôt de
ce niveau
donc vous
osez vous osez me parler d'éthique chez
moi les tiques en fait c'est de
respecter le consentement du patient
c'est de lui dire si cette injection
expérimentale elle va le rendre malade
ou pas parce que me dites pas qu'il y a
pas d'effet un désirable monsieur Véran
on est à 90 000 d'accord donc me dites
pas qu'il y en a pas eu c'est faux je
suis désolé et surtout moi mon éthique
elle est elle réside dans le fait où le
patient il doit être consentant moi
quand j'enlève ma blouse d'infirmière je
rentre chez moi je suis patiente
je suis une patiente et vous et vous
vous m'avez enlevé tous ces droits là
vous m'avez enlevé le droit d'être une
simple patiente je n'ai contaminé
personne je n'ai tué personne par contre
le fait que vous ayez laissé les gens
avec du doliprane chez eux oui ça ça a
certainement tuer des gens le fait que
vous ayez enlevé les soignants suspendus
de leurs hôpitaux oui ça a enlevé des
soignants au lit du patient parce que à
signaler que nous on est tous là en
début de pandémie d'accord moi en mars
2020 j'étais réserviste sanitaire dans
une EHPAD seul au milieu de Paris
et vous osez me dire que je n'ai pas
d'éthique
si vous l'avez dit Monsieur éthique de
se protéger contre les maladies
transmissibles quand on est soignant et
je l'assume madame vous êtes vacciné
contre l'hépatite B mais monsieur
40 ans l'hépatite B et là vous vous êtes
devant vous vous êtes porte-parole et
deux vins c'est-à-dire que vous savez me
dire si dans qu'est-ce qu'il a ce vaccin
vous appelez vaccin expérimental vous
lui reprochez quoi on va aller jusqu'au
bout du raisonnement pour vous il fait
quoi ce vaccin vous ne savez pas ce qui
va faire dans la notice il est noté et
vous êtes médecin vous devriez le savoir
vous devriez lire les notices
il est marqué qu'ils sont en étude
jusque quand décembre 2023 études
clinique chez moi
puisque vous savez me dire dans 10 ans
ce qui va se passer je vais vous dire
les choses vous ne faites pas confiance
au médecin avec lesquels vous travaillez
et vous voudrez qui vous fasse confiance
sur le nombre complet de médecins donc
les médecins recommandent le vaccin vous
les sortez de toute façon
on doit être 400 soignés
eux-mêmes mais c'est pas grave mais vous
croyez quoi
vous avez des milliards d'humains qui
ont été vaccinés vous êtes soignante
vous n'êtes pas patiente quand vous
travaillez dans un hôpital ou auprès de
malade vous n'êtes pas patient vous êtes
soignant Eric mais vous avez le droit
mais quand vous faites le choix encore
une fois de porter la blouse et si vous
êtes madame vous avez la mémoire de ce
qu'on vous a demandé quand vous avez mis
la blouse à première fois on vous a
demandé un certificat de vaccination en
fait on devient des objets quand on
devient infirmier non vous n'êtes pas
responsabilités
suspendu vous avez 52 ans infirmiers à
Nantes suspendu depuis novembre 2021
voilà incroyable incroyable ce qu'on
vient d'entendre tout à fait
spectaculaire tout à fait spectaculaire
vraiment aller au fond des choses j'ai
envie de vous proposer deux choses parce
qu'il faut gagner du temps moi je vois
l'heure qui passe et peut-être même de
vous faire un cadeau si vous accepterez
on verra tous les cadeaux première des
choses moi effectivement c'est de
rentrer un petit peu dans la logique
avec la réintégration des soignants
suspendus ok on en a déjà parlé on est
le dernier pays dans le monde à être à
la ramasse complètement on parle que de
pur logique vous rendre service rendre
service à tout le monde vous parliez
tout à l'heure de garder des artisans
sur place de garder des artisans en vie
est-ce que vous voulez garder des des
soignants
chose il faut les réintégrer c'est pure
logique mais deuxième chose est-ce que
vous acceptez la face caméra devant deux
trois quatre six millions de personnes
peu importe 22 millions
ici même là de venir répondre parce que
là c'est facile nous on est les salariés
subalterne mais un jour devenir
rencontrer en face à face le docteur
Amine Lille lui il a des choses à vous
dire il a des choses à vous expliquer ce
médecin notamment qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé en mars de ville 21 il y a un
homme qui a quelque chose à dire j'en ai
eu quelques-uns depuis le début
c'est logique en mars 2021 quelqu'un a
écrit au Conseil d'État attention ce
vaccin sera limité dans l'efficacité il
y aura des problématiques de variants et
la transmission sera énorme voilà c'est
vous qui avez écrit ça et juste après
c'était vacciné tout se protéger moi
j'aimerais qu'on pense un petit peu à
Karine une collègue de l'hôpital public
qui s'est suicidé mère de famille avec
deux enfants nous on rigole pas moi ça
fait 30 ans que je suis dans le soin 22
en soin palliatifs je suis passé par les
pompiers de Paris hôpitaux militaire
hôpitaux parisiens j'ai vacciné toute ma
carrière j'ai vacciné des stades entiers
ma femme mes enfants j'ai vacciné sur le
H1 maintenant on m'appelle antivax mais
je crois rêver j'ai toujours été à jour
sauf que quand je présente mes IgE mes
anticorps hépatiques B ça ça marche et
je me fais mon hépatite B comme un grand
mais quand je prends présente mes
anticorps naturels sarkov2 on me dit non
ça fonctionne pas dans mon service
monsieur j'ai vu des gens de 94 ans
guéri nettement à l'hiver mectine vous
avez refusé de parler à 500 médecins qui
vous ont mis en référé au Conseil d'État
vous pouvez soupirer 104 études
randomisées 27 pays 2017 je vous réponds
ou pas je termine c'est un secret de
polichinelle et vous refusez de parler
au docteur la minute vous refusez de
parler sur la logique et moi j'ai
toujours vacciné aujourd'hui
mais non je suis aujourd'hui
je voudrais presque fini je voudrais
dans un espace de volume
je suis monsieur je termine là-dessus je
suis je vide des poubelles en usine
alors que mon métier c'est soigner les
gens qui sont ici doivent savoir c'est
la Bérézina sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire mais c'est l'évaporation des
soignants nous avec le syndicat liberté
santé qu'on a été obligé de se créer on
est à année des paniers repas des
paniers repas des infirmières qui
dorment là là de l'hôpital public qui
dorment dans leur voiture alors que nous
on veut retourner en soins et mes
collègues triple d'oser mes collègues
triple d'oser qu'est-ce qu'elles ont
fait avec la quatrième dose zéro nada
elle le savent elles ont évité à 92%
c'est les chiffres de la NSM elles ont
évité la quatrième dose parce que votre
Paris biologique a raté ça s'est vu tous
les triples dosés se sont chopés
c'est justement la proposition d'amis
n'oublie pour vous face à ce monsieur
mais ça vous voyez c'est c'est c'est un
c'est un gant de soignant moi je vous le
jette je vous lance le défi venez venez
venez parler face à minuit c'est ça
cadeau on va voir si l'accès je vous
réponds ou sinon vous avez terminé on
peut on peut passer à autre chose c'est
comme vous voulez ici d'abord dire une
chose un oui j'ai de l'empathie et
beaucoup de sympathie y compris pour les
soignants et notamment pour les
soignants non vaccinés qui sont en
difficulté qui peuvent pas exercer leur
métier et je leur dis je non vraiment
vous seriez étonné et j'aurais dit que
je regrette le choix qu'ils ont fait je
regrette le choix qu'ils ont fait
je vais vous répondre sinon on va passer
vraiment ensuite je comprends le courant
qui est le vôtre quel courant mais oui
c'est le courant de l'hiver meknin j'ai
eu le droit à la chloroquine j'ai le
droit à la cloche ici j'ai eu le droit à
l'hiver le courant qui dit depuis 3 ans
qu'il existe un médicament miracle
secret que tel ou tel médecin a trouvé
dans son laboratoire sans démonstration
scientifique et
ne marche pas la chloroquine ne marche
pas la colchicine ne marche pas il y a
pas un seul pays au monde qui le
considère encore je vais vous dire un
truc j'écoute mais je l'assume
complètement c'est pas nouveau avec moi
la communauté scientifique et médicale
et pas que françaises européenne est
mondiale monsieur je dis juste que un
soignant un soignant qui considère qu'un
médicament qui n'a pas démontré son
efficacité qui n'a aucune validation ni
nationale ni internationale et qui dans
cette posture là je suis désolé et qui
refuse de se vacciner est un soignant en
qui je le dis en tant que médecin alors
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas confiance alors
après je vais vous dire les choses vous
avez vous avez c'est pas une décision
vous avez pas une décision politique
même si je l'endos et je l'assume encore
aujourd'hui mais vous avez ce qu'on
appelle la Haute Autorité de Santé
d'accord qui n'est pas une entité
gouvernementale qui est autonome
toutes les recommandations scientifiques
de notre pays vous savez et je les ai
sollicités je crois trois ou quatre fois
différents intervalles en leur posant la
question et en disant toujours que le
jour où la Haute Autorité de santé nous
dit réintégrer les soignants on le fera
et pourquoi je suis
la même
positions
magiques de novembre 2022 on est en
janvier 2023 ça va
Autorité de Santé systématiquement
répondu que les conditions ne
permettaient pas la révélation
je suis désolé encore une fois pour les
soignants
il y a beaucoup de questions beaucoup de
gens disent il y avait il a intégré il y
a des pays d'abord il y a des pays dans
lesquels il y avait pas eu de suspension
de soignants d'obligation des pays qui
l'ont mis en place et ensuite nous on
fait alors je suis plus ministre en
charge de la santé mais je m'en
successeur qui est un urgentiste de
métier à continuer à saisir les
autorités scientifiques pour leur rep
posé la question comme il y a encore des
vagues régulières ça vous aura pas
échappé on a connu encore une vague et
un mois et demi deux mois j'en considéré
que les conditions de sécurité sanitaire
n'étaient pas réunies d'accord donc vous
pouvez lever tout tout en fait
une chose l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants et une chose prenez des
médicaments
inefficaces non démontrés utilisés nulle
part dans le monde avec tous les sur la
base des dires d'un médecin qui par
ailleurs je crois Maya partir avec la
communauté médicale j'en ai vécu
tellement pendant trois ans
vous pouvez me dire parce qu'on est dans
le cadre bien de l'obligation vaccinale
c'est vous qui le rappelez est-ce qu'à
100% vous pouvez me dire que si je me
fais injecter je ne ferai pas d'effet
indésirables puisque vous m'obligez à le
faire est-ce que pour cent vous pouvez
me dire que je peux me faire injecter
vous êtes infirmière par les deux
vacciner la vaccination est un cadeau
pour l'humanité
des maladies qui terrasser les
populations autrefois et parce que les
gens parce que certains parents
moi j'ai vacciné je suis pour les
vaccins il y a des parce que des parents
avaient arrêté de vacciner leurs enfants
contre la rougeole qu'on avait des
résurgences de rougeole avec des formes
graves on a mis dans la loi l'obligation
vaccinale pour toute la population
contre la rougeole et on l'assume aussi
ça doit être 1964 à peu près le vaccin
donc oui ou non monsieur à 100% que vous
pouvez me donner
j'avais compris que les soignants non
vaccinés ne voulaient pas d'IRL messager
mais lorsqu'il trouver un vaccin dit
traditionnel il le prendrait et moi je
l'ai compris que quand la numéro 2 de
Pfizer au Parlement européen Jeannette
small s'exprime face à Peter Ross le
député néerlandais et qu'elle lui
demande et qui lui demande est-ce que
vous avez testé l'efficacité sur la
transmission avant la mise en route de
cette pseudo vaccination en elle-même
conditionnel elle répond en riant non il
y a eu aucun test sur la transmission
vous en avez vous-même parlé au Conseil
d'État c'est pour ça que ça a raté moi
je suis pour les vaccins les vrais
vaccins ça il s'agit techniquement d'un
anneau d'injection de nanoparticules
lipidique d'ARN messager a visé
immunogène de protéines Spike en phase
expérimentale 3 c'est énervant à dire du
coup on sert à tout le monde vaccin il
faut des vrais vaccins après vous avez
vous-même parlé de des mutants un
coronavirus mais ça n'arrête pas de
muter tous les trois mois est-ce que
vous faites vacciner quelqu'un de la de
la grippe avec le vaccin de l'année
dernière
[Musique]